welcome to the Macmillan report I'm
Marilyn Wilkes your host and our guest
is own a Hathaway who is the Gerard C
and Bernice Latrobe Smith professor of
international law at the Yale Law School
her current research focuses on the
foundations of modern international law
the intersection of u.s. constitutional
law and international law the
enforcement of international law and the
law of armed conflict
professor Hathaway has published more
than 25 Law Review articles today we'll
talk with her about the new book she
co-authored with Yale Law Professor
Scott Shapiro titled the
internationalist how a radical plan to
outlaw war remade the world
welcome professor Hathaway thanks it's
nice to be here let's begin with an
overview of your book tell us about it
well the book argues that the world used
to look very different than it looks
today
that war was perfectly legal and
legitimate that states could use it to
write any kind of wrong
and as a result conquest to his legal
gunboat diplomacy was legal
you couldn't be tried for the crime of
aggression because there wasn't any such
thing and the world was that this
produce was very blue brutal and bloody
and and a pretty terrible place to live
and that conquest was so common that the
average state could expect to suffer
conquest roughly once in an ordinary
human lifetime and we argue that all
changed and it changed as a result of a
much maligned international agreement
the kellogg-briand pact of 1928 which
outlawed war and that was the beginning
of the unraveling of this old system
okay and you talked about the old way or
the old world order tell us a little bit
more about that specifically and how
it's changed to today yeah so the old
world order was a world where if a state
had any kind of a grievance with another
state they would first try to resolve it
diplomatically but if
that wasn't successful they could go to
war over it so we found all these old
war manifestos that states had issued
against one another saying here's why
we're going to war and they would say
things like you interfered with our
trade relations so we're going to war or
they would say things like we you are
failing to repay debt and so we're going
to war over that or you're getting too
powerful and we're afraid you're
eventually going to Nevada so we're
going to work there's there was even a
manifesto for the u.s. invading Mexico
so in the spanish-american war
mexican-american war the United States
went to war against Mexico because
Mexico failed to repay nearly two
million dollars in debts many people
think of that war as having been caused
by skirmishes on the border and that was
a contributing factor but really the
legal reason for going to war was
because Mexico had agreed to repay a
series of debts and then defaulted on
the debt repayments and the u.s. went to
war to claim territory much of what's
now California and New Mexico much of
southwestern United States is now part
of the United States because we were we
went to war to reclaim that territory as
repayment for the debt okay so tell us a
little bit more of the act that changed
to bring about this new world order yeah
so as I said war was perfectly legal and
legitimate for hundreds of years
World War one was an old world order war
States went to war against one another
over a variety of grievances some of
them bigger than others some of them
were petty and at the end of the war
which was brutal and bloody and millions
of people had died there was a
widespread effort to try and find a way
to end the war and there was a man whose
name was salmon Levinson who was a
bankruptcy lawyer in Chicago who we'd
never heard of before but we realized he
was a guy who came up with this idea of
outlawing more he thought war was
terribly destructive it was a waste and
that the if the countries of the world
could get together and agree to outlaw
war then
then things might change and he created
an organization the foundation for
outlawry of war he worked together with
politicians and peace activists to get
this idea kind of broadly circulated and
eventually that led to a treaty in 1928
where nearly every country in the world
gathered together in Paris to outlaw war
and they reached renounce war as a tool
of state policy within a year nearly
every nation in the world had renounced
the right to go to war and had given up
this tool that they had used for
hundreds of years to right wrongs now
the problem was that they hadn't really
thought about what comes next
so they hadn't really thought through
how do we then take this promise and
make it a reality how do we take this
idea of outlawing war and find other
ways to achieve the same purposes that
were used to serve you know if a state
fails to repay a debt how are we going
to collect on that debt if someone
interferes to their trade lations how
are we going to address that if a state
breaks the rules and conquerors
territory what are we going to do about
it they hadn't really thought that
through but they had taken the really
important first step of outlying war
okay and what was the next step so the
next step was trying to figure out okay
if war is no longer legal what are we
going to do instead and so in 1931 Japan
invaded Manchuria and the world had to
figure out how are we going to enforce
this pact
we've just renounce the right to go to
war can we go to war to enforce the
prohibition of war how are we going to
enforce this rule and Henry Stimson who
had been a classmate of salmon
Levinson's here at Yale he had been in
corresponding with salmon Levinson and
Levinson had said well one way to
enforce the rule is just simply to
refuse to recognize that the territory
that a state has seized is theirs so for
hundreds of years whenever a state took
territory as the United States took much
of the southwestern United what is now
in southwestern United States everyone
assumed okay it's now yours and there
wasn't any kind of disagreement about
the legal right so the territory even if
the war was waged for illegitimate
reasons and the big step that Simpson
made and what
became known as the Stimson doctrine was
to say you might take the territory but
it's not yours we are not going to
recognize this as being Japanese
territory we're going to refuse to
recognize and a treaties or agreements
that are brought about as a result of
this invasion and that was really the
first time in human history something
like that had happened and that they
refused to recognize the conquest that
refused to recognize agreements brought
about through gunboat diplomacy and that
had a real impact and changing the value
of taking territory and because if you
took it you couldn't now sell the goods
you couldn't issue passports marriages
aren't recognized all the things that
you get out of having the territories
being part of yours you no longer got
and that was a first step they then had
to figure out all the rest of the pieces
how are they going to manage without
gunboat diplomacy which had been used
for hundreds of years how are they going
to enforce the rule against aggression
is there going to be a crime of
aggression ultimately I decided yes and
that's resulted in the Nuremberg trials
after World War Two and so each of these
pieces they had to be in to put into
place and part of the story we tell the
internationalist that the book is named
for our the people are trying to figure
that out they're struggling with how do
we take this idea that war is not going
to be the way we're going to resolve our
disputes anymore and how are we going to
create a new system with a set of rules
that are going to be effective and what
are those going to look like okay and
let's talk about the internationalist I
believe there's four that you highlight
in your book yeah so I mean there's a
whole cast of characters in the book
there are four key characters one of
them is Sam and Levinson who I mentioned
and he has a colleague James T Shotwell
who is a something of a friend of me
we'd say today they got along but they
didn't always agree about what the
outlaw tree movement should look like
and how it should achieve its goals
Shotwell took the idea of outlawing more
and he's part of the reason that are
stood by on the French Foreign Minister
got interested in the idea and proposed
in fact the idea back to the United
States and so he was one who helped make
the agreement come to fruition
even though Levinson didn't
appreciate his meddling nor did Frank
Kellogg the Secretary's day who was
actually incredibly upset that Briand
had made the proposal and although
Kellogg later won the Nobel Peace Prize
for it he initially was completely
opposed to it and so there are a whole
cast of really interesting characters
some of them are appealing some of them
really unappealing 11 sends one of my
favorite another is Hersh lauter POC 2
was one of the key figures thinking
through all the ways in which the rules
were going to become effective he wrote
the opening statements at Nuremberg he
was a person who really helped figure
out how to put all the different pieces
together including the crime of
aggression and holding the Nazis liable
for waging an illegal war nearly his
entire family had been killed in the
Holocaust and so he was there for the
initial opening argument but he just
couldn't sit through the trial was so
incredibly painful for him and so I mean
all these people are incredibly
interesting and what's fascinating about
it for me is that they are real people
struggling with ideas they don't really
know exactly what to do and they're
trying to figure it out and they're
arguing with one another and they're you
know they've got kind of envy and
they've got their own personal interest
in it and it's so interesting to see how
you know they're they become real
they're real people and I mean they're
the ones who are responsible for giving
us a legal order that we have but
they're just like us and that they have
the same kinds of desires and jealousies
but they're really deeply committed to
an idea which is creating a world where
war is no longer going to be the main
way in which states resolve their
disputes with one another and they're
devoted to trying to figure out how to
make that work ok and what about the UN
what role does the UN play in your story
so many people think all this starts
with the UN so they think ok yeah I see
that the modern League order is
different from the way the old one was
but really that's because the United
Nations and the United Nations is really
important but it plays it what's key to
understand is that the UN is not just
kind of inventing things at a whole
cloth it's not
coming up with the idea for the first
time the central idea is in the United
Nations Charter first appear in the 1928
Calabrian pact and all this effort of
working out what the rules are going to
look like is what makes the United
Nations Charter possible and in fact we
found that James T Shotwell who I
mentioned was the one who kind of worked
on outlawry afore and who was kind of in
competition slash you know agreed with
Sam and Levinson he in fact was a member
of a group formed within the State
Department by another one of our
internationalists Sumner Welles who was
an undersecretary of state in the State
Department and he convened a group
including James T shot well to think
through ok now that Wars broken out
again how are we going to keep the peace
after this war and they come up with a
first draft of the United Nations and in
fact we found a document in the
Roosevelt library with the initials JT s
James Thomas shot well which we believe
is a very first draft of what would
become the United Nations Charter and in
that drafty actually cut and paste the
pacts text directly at the very
beginning then eventually that turns
into the article article 2 for the
prohibition on use of force in the
modern Charter but you can really see
how the ideas of the Charter are coming
not just indirectly but directly out of
the pact and they're building all these
institutions around it to try and make
it effective ok and and looking at the
pact today does it still resonate with
what is going on in the world today
I mean do you think it will survive well
this is a real challenge at this moment
we see these this world order once again
up for grabs and I think what the book
helps us see is the way that things are
is relatively new the idea that war is
an illegal legitimate means of resolving
disputes is relatively new and there's
no reason that it can't change again and
part of this is meant to be a warning
and to say look the world used to look
very different it was much worse
for all the flavors and problems that
the modern legal order and we're very
honest about all of those it's not
perfect but it's so much better than
what came before and be very careful
what you put at risk the efforts to
they're the threats to withdraw from the
World Trade Organization for instance
the pulling back of support for the
United Nations the kind of threats to
use military force in ways that wouldn't
be consistent with the United Nations
Charter these are very dangerous things
to be doing because they put this
achievement of the international that's
very much at risk and what we're trying
to tell people in the book is see what
the internationalists achieve see how
important that transformation wants see
how difficult it was and be careful
before you put that all risk okay very
interesting thank you so much for being
here with us today and sharing your work
thank you thanks so much for having me
for more information about Professor
Hathaway and her research please visit
our website at macmillan report yale.edu
be sure to join us again for another
episode of the Macmillan report made
possible through funding from the
Whitney and Betty Macmillan Center for
International and area studies at Yale
you
[Music]